hey gang thanks for tuning into our you
garbage yeah guys please make sure you
subscribe that way you get the episodes
as they come out hmm thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley Oh
baby
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage the show where we sit down
with your favorite comedians and fun if
they grow up classy her if they're
complete trash I'm your host H Foley
coming at you on a scorching day here
Studio B gasps Digital Studios in the
East Village
everything is sticking together folks I
need some [ __ ] gold Bond stat my
co-host coming at you from right next to
me he's the brains behind the operation
he's got his name on the lease pleasure
gentlemen as they always say the next
time you reach them for a best pal do
yourself a [ __ ] favor and make it a
kippie oh this guy's on sale two for one
give it up for Kevin James Ryan
everybody hey what's up everybody thanks
for tuning in we appreciate it as always
if you haven't already please make sure
you rate review subscribe on iTunes and
also you full video available on YouTube
you can subscribe there as well we
appreciate all support as we get this
thing off the [ __ ] ground I love you
baby
absolutely I love you too kitty I don't
know if that was directed at me but I'm
gonna take it and I love are extremely
extremely special guests gotta get on
the podcast today let's go over this
[ __ ] rap sheet that I got in front of
me right here we're gonna start off with
the acting as an actor some of his
credits has appeared on The Andy Dick
show the man show Louie Aqua Teen Hunger
Force comedy bang bang santa clarita
diet of course crashing okay as a writer
he's wrote on politically incorrect The
Ellen DeGeneres Show the man show lucky
Louie crashing again as a [ __ ]
producer got 22 episodes of the man show
eight episodes of crashing he's also
appeared on the Howard Stern Show Late
Night with Conan
Oh Brian he has not one but two Comedy
Central Presents you've seen him on your
mom's house The Late Show with David
Letterman Jimmy Kimmel lives
Chelsea Lately the Joe Rogan experience
he has a stand-up special life on stage
you know I'm from Fitz talk radio and
the 2006 host at a AVN Awards I don't
know if he's garbage or not but I know
he's got a little bit of [ __ ] cash on
I'm up hanging out right now ladies and
gentlemen give us a nice big round of
applause for mr. Greg Fitzsimmons
everybody let me tell you something let
me ask you something I need $40 here
when you're Irish it doesn't matter how
much cash you have oh for sure for sure
that's why I was so excited to have you
I'm like he's like that's a successful
career but he is Irish trash from the
East Coast which you can know no amount
of money can shake this still saving the
the grocery bags and putting them in the
in the cabinet oh we use a tea bag
[Laughter]
[Music]
squeeze and everything out of it
I know man it's in our blood did you
ever get sent to school with you
Whittier where your lunch bag is the
[ __ ] old bread bag that was finished
yes when that kid sat next to you were
like yo this guy's definitely got lice
yeah that was a tough look in the
lunchroom with that thing oh my god
great thank you I used to go to school
and my mom never bought us proper boots
oh so she used to take those those bread
bags
yeah just put them over your feet then
you'd stick them into your snake dude
what is this Angela's Ashes Jesus Christ
did that I did that [ __ ] in the 90s my
mom was like get the plastic bags and
we'd go out and play in the snow and
like I was wearing like air walks our
with ha that's [ __ ] trash my mom one
time wouldn't buy a sleds for though for
the winter so of course it snowed one
day we had a snow day she was off work
had nothing doing this this broad send
us out to the hill in front of the whole
neighborhood with two [ __ ] cardboard
box
we didn't go anywhere and she was
bitching like we didn't know how to use
it like what is this the [ __ ] North
Shore figuring how to surf this is
[ __ ]
Gregg thank you so much for doing the
show man we appreciate you being here
and coming on with this tell me
something to monitor over your shoulder
you guys can't yeah we gotta keep we're
in the small studio Gregg we're just
starting out what do you want
you look like midgets we can't afford
that nice green paint you got behind you
that's Home Depot paint right there
that's two coats that's two coats and a
primer this guy's got LIBOR money here's
here's trash I didn't I didn't have
somebody painted I did it myself with my
daughter yeah my daughter thought it
would be funny to write 666 and I'm not
gonna say what else you wrote on it and
then so we had to put two more coats
over that one cup Jesus keep an eye on
that kid I'll give you bonus points if
you still have the blue painters tape up
at the top and you can see the roof has
some green nice drop ceiling too really
I see yeah it's real classic wait is
that your are you in the house right now
are you at your office
no I have an office that's not tell us
tell us a little bit you know we want to
talk about now you know you mentioned
you mentioned your daughter we want to
talk about your family kind of how you
run the house today but tell us a little
bit you know where you grew up how you
grew up the family situation well I
lived in the Bronx until I was about
eight and my my parents are both from
the Bronx okay
grandparents and well my grandparents
are all from Ireland but then they
immigrated to the Bronx damn and and
then my dad was you know made some money
he was in radio in New York so he became
a really big radio personality in New
York for my whole life and so we made
some money and we moved up to Tarrytown
Western he's real very nice a couple
really good restaurants in Tarrytown
right there are yeah it's gotten very
trendy when I grew up there it wasn't it
wasn't that nice it was it's a real
right and wrong side of the tracks kind
of a town it's
like downtown there's a there's a
General Motors plant so there was a lot
of tenement apartments and housing
projects downtown and by the train
station and it was actually pretty
dangerous and it was like it was race
riots and there was there was a lot of
drugs and then I grew up I grew up in a
good part of town but my parents
couldn't shake that growing up broke
mentality short though even though we
had money my mother never spent it and
we lived like [ __ ] bomb same exact
story we I grew up in the suburbs of
Philly there was money came and went
there was times where there was and
times where there wasn't cuz you know
they're you know idiots that don't know
how to manage money so it came and went
but at the same time like when it was
there was and we still lived like we
were you know dirt poor
yeah yeah yeah it's like you know we we
belong to a country club and then we
would go there and my mother would give
us two dollars a day to buy lunch and
whatever sodas and snacks do we want it
that's not gonna get you a crab cake
what the [ __ ] I won't pay for the lemon
on the ice day mile all the other kids
are putting it on the account like put
to the Charleston's pleas and you're
like yeah the Fitzsimmons are there
pinching pennies the order from was
Kevin meanie
no way it was a waiter I was a kid and
he used to come down to the pool with a
red blazer and a black bowtie what it's
like you wanted I go give me a coke
Cabot he was long like goddamn
Fitzsimmons boy crazy person
how many brothers and sisters did you
have growing up alright large Irish
family or small well Irish twins me and
my brother are 12 months apart nice they
talked about flying too close to the Sun
12 ounces things getting loose in
Tarrytown I like it yeah
and then my sisters three and a half
years younger and she still she lives in
Westchester and then my brothers in
Brooklyn
ok ok small for an Irish Catholic
found some all for an Irish Catholic
family you're one of what 45 or what is
it my mom's won a nine we're like [ __ ]
ticks in Philadelphia yeah my mom was
one of seven and then my my grandparents
one was one of 13 and one was one of 11
that's wild what [ __ ]
and how was it growing up up in
Tarrytown so you moved up there you guys
kind of settled in and how what was the
what was the lifestyle like growing up
there it was good you know it was like
we kind of like we had a we had a lake
so in the winters we did a lot of played
a lot of hockey nine go there at night
and we'd skate we you know throw a case
of beers on the bank of the lake and
then we'd skate around and and then the
summers we'd swim in the lake and we go
to the Hudson River we're right on
Hudson River so we did a lot of we did a
lot lot of drinking and drugs growing up
starting at a very young age my kind of
guy really I mean we were like 12 13
years old and we were we were getting
[ __ ] up like yeah four or five nights
a week same and all my friend's parents
were alcoholics of course sure everybody
noticed there was just booze everywhere
my friends all had oh you always got to
hang out with the kid who's got the
older sibling sure yeah and they'll get
stuff for you yeah come on Donnie get us
a six-pack Yeah right
and you know you buy he get six-pack he
keeps one that's all yeah for sure he's
got a wet his beak that's trash that's
all you're asking for give me one give
me one if you're not good if you're
ripping off 12 year olds for one [ __ ]
and Mike's Hard Lemonade that's trash
well you remember what you were drinking
back then it wasn't Mike's Hard Lemonade
it was something probably really shitty
yeah it was
well Boone's Farm strawberry wine and
then for weed Budweiser drinkers nice
nothing wrong with a bud heavy Oh get a
nice cold at the bar come on I [ __ ]
love it
now was that it was that a similar story
with with you and your friends growing
up like did most of their parents kind
of start out in the city or start out
somewhere else and then kind of got a
little money and then moved out there
yeah
was a lot of that Tarrytown is
definitely a place where well you know
Westchester in general is where if
you're from the Bronx need to make some
money move to Westchester from Queens
make money you go to Long Island oh
there's some Staten Island he makes some
money you go to Jersey mm-hmm so it was
a lot of that but there was a lot of
multi-generation there one of my friends
Tommy Buchi was Carpenters Union and his
grandfather was in the carpet yeah they
ran the Carpenters Union and they were
like the family in town that had cousins
and everybody had some kind of a union
job with a very Union town because of
General Motors or because they they did
a lot of construction and there was a
lot a lot of stuff on the Hudson River a
lot of jobs down there so it was very
blue-collar working-class and then there
was the people at the top of the hill
like me what's up looking down at the
ball purse that's right but still trash
still trash dude you can't shake it
that's what we've been finding out as we
do the show more and more it's like
regards its its generational it takes a
couple generations to real like your
kids will be in a better position you
know there'll be a little less trashy
than you were and it's gonna keep going
down the line yeah do you feel like you
know you said that your that your
parents kind of had that mentality
because they started out poor and then
they got some money but they still kept
that do you feel like that wore off on
you a little bit with your family now
no I'm cheapest father yeah that's what
I'm always worried I Drive a Prius and
you know I buy everything in Ross Dress
for Less but my wife my wife grew up in
Manhattan and she she grew up in a
family that they didn't have a ton of
money but they bought quality things
okay she's yeah so she's half Irish half
Jewish and mix there you go wait what
they would buy like you know like a like
a you'd buy your suit from Brooks
Brothers and you keep it for the rest of
your life her sweater that was made in
England that you know so she's kind of
instilled that in the kids a little bit
they've got a little bit more class okay
all right I've got the same thing out of
Buddy who I want remember here
like tan I heard his mom say you spend
the money on stuff that matters like my
bed she's like bedding we spend a lot of
money on bedding I was like imagine how
my bed with it was like Mickey Mouse
sheets from like you know her passed
down from right my oldest cousin I'm
like I had I had a bed that was so old
it was a twin bed and it had [ __ ]
metal Springs in the boxspring and so I
used to jerk off but you could hear it
it was so squeaky squeaky
I would like put my foot on the bed
board to try to hold it still oh yeah I
would almost arch my back and all rest
all rest and I thought I was better lay
with it the spider-man yeah one hand on
one hand on the wall the other on the on
the on the footer' did you ever get
caught jerking off when you were a kid I
came I came home from from school one
day and I sat on my bed and it didn't
creak and I was like what the [ __ ]
happened I look up it was a can of three
in one oil on my dresser my mother had
come up and oiled my bed jerking off
from dead you pull your little root up
there but what I what an Irish repressed
emotion thing to not say yeah not a word
was said and passive-aggressively leaves
the can of [ __ ] oil I know what
you're doing you dirtballs stop it she's
serving a meatloaf that night she gives
you a little wink like I don't know what
you're up to
yeah Greg you want to wash your hands
again before and your wrists in your
forearm did you share a room with your
with you with your brother for a while
or was in separate rooms it was the only
time we lived together we we moved
actually from the Bronx we were in
Philly for a year my dad got a radio job
there and we lived in Cherry Hill New
Jersey okay Cherry Hills clean money
right there yeah and so we shared a room
there but we got in fistfights every day
and so I had to sleep in the living room
that's [ __ ] Irish twins Irish twins
are a little physical ah Irish people
are a little physical yeah me and my
brother 18 months apart we fought every
single every single [ __ ] day from
like 12 years old to like 17
every summer we would get no fight yeah
right good time so a good time but
you're also super close because like
sure you do play sports together yeah
yeah nerf bat we played contact nerf
basketball just body slam
yeah contact nerf basketball when you
got to a certain age on your knees was
like the funnest [ __ ] time ever that
and some floor hockey we played floor
hockey in the basement but we had these
roller skates with metal wheels and so
one guy we one guy would belt up a
couple pillows to his legs and play
goalies yeah yeah of course
and Ivan Reitman movie I [ __ ] love
that that's awesome alright so let's get
in the Sun we're gonna play a little
game here Greg called are you garbage
boy Kevin and I are gonna ask you a
series of questions we would like you to
answer the questions as honest as
possible and if it sparks any memories
or any stories please elaborate sound
good I'm I'm ready I want to start out
and just know so that now you you guys
live out in Los Angeles correct yeah
Venice Beach ooh very nice what's the
name of the grocery store that you go to
well you know there's we try to go to
Trader Joe's a lot because it's cheaper
and better sure then we end up going to
Whole Foods which is super expensive and
then there's a place around the corner
called err wand yeah her wand it's like
spelled like ER e HW om and it's the
biggest douchebag festive [ __ ] cash
though we've never heard those three
answers and we asked that it's always
like two shitty ones and maybe a Trader
Joe's if they had a good week they had
the weekly number or something right is
like you know $15 loads of olive bread
and you know $12 cans of peanut butter
and it's filled with guys that are
dressed like it's the 1800s yeah
cut and Swiss cheese with a [ __ ]
razor blade to get it really really thin
are you an almond butter family yeah
holy [ __ ] that's like [ __ ] 14 bucks
my wife tries to get she tries to make
her own it [ __ ] old foods I'm like no
Duds
we don't have make your own almond
butter money I got a question I do do
against digital you call your wife totes
she's European English English isn't
their first language he doesn't know it
yet
hey dumb broad wins the almond butter
let's go yeah you want to get a knuckle
same why I ought it holy [ __ ] no we get
the almond butter at Costco it's
gigantic and it's cheaper than peanut
butter yeah I just took you down a peg
buddy oh [ __ ] Trader Joe's Whole Foods
in some fancy place I bet you they make
sushi at that other at the other store
don't they yeah they make sushi and they
make what do you call focaccia bread
with different toppings on it yeah man
sadly with salad bar and yeah it's
pretty it's pretty special a valet
parking what wallet yep la that's that's
a very la thing all right sure that's
clean livin yeah damn this guy's got a
car and he goes to errands
yeah how much cash you have in your
wallet right now tell me that he looks I
love him I love him he's definitely got
a hundred in there with the blue thing
and it's [ __ ] rush whoa no fits dog is
doing I yeah a couple of ones the grease
and kids I like it I play golf and I do
a lot of gambling out there so I got to
be ready I love it do you currently
belong to a country club
I do not all right you flood deep but
you play on private courses sometimes
yeah you playing on public courses
mostly public get this guy off my screen
right now let me ask you this you take a
Carter do you get a caddy I carry my bag
oh that is old speed you use the caddy
ever I was at for about five years there
you go that's why that is old school
right there that you can
I weighed like 115 pounds and I'd go out
there you know this is this is back in
the 80s when she put [ __ ] range balls
in there these heavy leather bags to
right the [ __ ] Rodney Dangerfield's
yeah exactly it's got a beer tap in it
hey don't tell me Jewish I would go out
there with two [ __ ] bags and it was
at Knollwood Country Club it was hilly
as [ __ ] we belonged to it but then I
started catting when I'm sure I stuck
with it that's good money man yeah I
guess so it was I would get $12 a bag Oh
her 18 eggs for $24 do you go out twice
a day or once yeah I go out twice a day
a ham yeah about they say it's about
seven miles walking a golf boys a hat
again that's not good money it honestly
took me a really long time to get back
into just watching golf and liking golf
like I love Tiger but when I was a kid
like my second or third job was was as a
caddy at this like really really rich
Country Club outside of Philly and the
guy the first day like the golfers were
just such [ __ ] dicks to me and they
were just such [ __ ] all the time
that I was like I hate golf
they knew you're a white trash you
didn't belong saw me comin yeah you were
made for caddy and to with those chubby
shoulders he's not chubby he's big-boned
Greg put four bags on that I'll tell you
this beginners get that Foley boys built
like a nice speaking Irish trash and
fighting with your brother me and my
brother both got an opportunity to caddy
at the Philmont Country Club for this
celebrity tournament in the late 80s
maybe early 90s and it was like Charles
Barkley Chris Carter all these [ __ ]
big people were there and me and my
brother were in a foursome with with
Chris Carter the wide receiver and we
were carrying the other 3 people's bag
Chris Carter was carrying his own and me
and my brothers started getting in
fights over who would carry the second
bag at what hole and we ended up getting
into a fistfight right in front of the
four of them Chris Carter like had to
break it up he said come on now fellas
act professional
again sorry about that Chris Carter
[ __ ] dirtbag Irish kids let's fight
another 90 that is garbage dude we're
fighting over the bag line I'll cook you
all carry okay shut up we started like
pushing each other like wow dude I can't
I once caddy for rusty Staub and Keith
Hernandez ooh
teeth Hernandez
yep holy [ __ ] how cool was he gorgeous
man he's something else huh man he's a
real man yeah he is a ray there was
something about those those mustaches
back then were [ __ ] yeah man I just
really worked I even saw saw a video of
Piazza and like from that era how much
the the player has changed as far as
like what they look like
yeah and this is without the juice are
they still juicing in baseball I would
assume so probably not to the level but
it like you know it's not like bonds and
[ __ ] yeah so so level but maybe a
little CBD every once in a while mixed
in with the chia seeds hmm yeah right
all right let's stay focus here we're
not letting you off the hook here you
tryna you trying to pander to us with
sports conversation you're in the hot
seat buddy all right with your [ __ ]
Costco peanut butter it's almond butter
though that's that's I get shirts at
Costco that's that licking caviar at the
gas station Kirkland all the way people
keep saying we have to have them on I'm
like it'll just end a fiscally between
the three of us in-studio if we have
them in studio man all right have you
ever skied in your jeans yes oh oh yes
recently Greg now growing up okay we
would go up to Bear Mountain
yeah I was just up there last weekend
really cooking up man I got a bear
mountain and you know that the the the
bread bags on the feet
jeans charities I had a Jean
jacket with a thermal hoody what yeah a
giant's hat we got the free fulfilling
up 10 times yeah that's like
misunderstood teen stars ship the jean
jacket with the [ __ ] abuse the
duality of that yeah it's crazy
did you ever put any patches on your
jean jacket oh yeah kidding I only
conscious but I but I got the I had the
doors what do they call it when they do
they spray it on airbrushed
airbrush Oh airbrushed on the back of my
to Levi jacket
they were Levi jacket guys and there
were Lee jacket got right jacket Eve I
Jack yeah yeah Lee jackets were [ __ ]
trash don't come around Aaron that [ __ ]
Levi's or nothing you know if you got a
Wrangler that that dot you're sleeping
on the streets yeah if you got a
Wrangler it's got no sleeves on it
takedown on filters in short yeah all
right what do you got big guy what do I
got do you cut your own grass right now
currently no yeah no I know okay now
we're [ __ ] talking to a gentleman
yeah let me ask you this more specific
question about your lawn care if I might
mr. Fitzsimmons you have a landscaper
yeah I guess you could call him a
landscaper we we have mowed it's
California so we have mostly kind of
rubbery plants succulents okay
succulents are like cactus type yes they
don't need a lot of water right and and
then we have decomposed granite which is
like a it's like a sandy rocky hard Pat
surface so that we only have a very
small amount of grass gotcha it doesn't
take a lot of work to do our lawn the
guys in and out because they call it
blow and go out here cuz they just come
in with the big [ __ ] v8 engine on
their back yeah the hose and they just
blow everything off your lawn this guy's
done the cut no grass what the [ __ ] I've
never even heard of
someone's living in the future no grass
out here on the west side of LA you're
not allowed to 70% of your lawn has to
be non grass I'm so much water we got
your house all the time
it sounds like tell that to your parents
generation they'll call that commie
[ __ ] old me I can't have grass this
is [ __ ] American where's the dog
gonna take a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
thing is the bread bags all right so you
don't cut your own grass that's pretty
classy I like it there is something
classy about cutting your own grass but
if you deal with an electric lawnmower
that's [ __ ] that's bad news
I should say in my last house I did mow
the lawn and then I got my son to mow
the lawn that was his first we were
there for about five or six years and we
we did mower on grass that's the Irish
mentality I like very nice right that
holds up that's good what I was gonna
ask you about about the lawn care is if
you had a landscaper I think a real
classy move is when when you got a rich
guy and they don't let you put the big
mower on the front lawn they make you
cut the front lawn with a small mower I
don't know if you guys are aware of that
if you ever work landscaping but I
always thought that was a classy move
they make you use like it like a like a
regular so their lines aren't as big
yeah push mower yeah push that's what we
call it and yeah that's real uppity [ __ ]
I feel we'll get there we'll get there
one day
we gotta get okay does anybody I got
this cuz I know a little bit about you
when was the last time you were in a
fight because you got you're a bit of a
hothead I am blows it's been a it's been
a while it was probably about seven or
eight years ago not that long you're in
your 50s what are you talking about yeah
you still fight was it like a
supermarket or something
road rage there was a guy I was driving
and this guy was coming down the street
and he was purposely swerving at cars
trying to like push he was like a madman
he was like kind of people off the road
so I pulled my car right in front of
them
and I got out and I went up to him and
his window was open and he on sunglasses
and I punched him across the side of his
head and sunglasses went flying out the
other window and then and then he turned
out to be a [ __ ]
didn't get out of the car didn't say
[ __ ] and then he just backed up and he
went around my car you a funny thing is
I was on my way to the hardware store
with my friend will Hayes I had a coffee
cup I'm drinking coffee and driving and
then I pulled in front of the guy I go
hold my coffee I got out hit him got
back and I go give me my coffee just
kept driving I bet he didn't say a
[ __ ] word after that the whole way to
the hardware store yeah yeah he paid you
when you went first strike in a car yeah
through the window through the window
well the window was down
yeah but through the window damn was he
running his mouth when you walked up no
he didn't say [ __ ] he was just a guy you
know some in LA people get this sense of
aggression winter inside their bubble of
their car yeah sure yeah yeah they
forget that there's real people on the
other side and that you yeah and that if
they wouldn't do that in person they
would only do it in their car so course
he shrunk and became a [ __ ] as soon as
I hit him dude that is the [ __ ] dawg
look the [ __ ] away all right holy [ __ ] I
love it that is such a go back to a
trashy Irish genetics it you just it's
it's every one of my uncles everyone it
doesn't clicks there you go well I gotta
hit this that's what it is this is which
goes yeah no longer in control and I
have no idea how I've never hit my kids
my wife yeah though I honestly do have
some controllers sure yeah with
strangers oh yeah yeah for sure this
guy's beaten up guys on the 101 what so
[ __ ] I love it he's like yeah we do
almond butter I also punch strangers in
the head I smack the [ __ ] out of my
pediatrician telling me the kid needs
braces [ __ ] talk to me uh holy Sh
alright you're up big guy let me ask you
this some hygiene questions do you clip
or bite your nails
I only bite bite ok I take the nail
clipper out every once in a while to
treat myself alright dude I love biting
a good nail I tell you I don't know what
it is they just grow magically all
sudden you got like a nice little
[ __ ] little fatty right there pick
that off but some question would be have
you ever picked your teeth with the
fingernail you bit off oh absolutely
yeah this is I don't bite them you can
see them I don't over bite them they're
actually pretty pretty well groomed for
a guy the guys I got a little shine on
them too
yeah yeah I get it I get it I get the
corner and then they get a nice peel I
only do it when I'm driving I throw them
out the window and then and then I eat
whatever [ __ ] dirt is a little slice
of dirt in there yeah little cute in
your mouth yeah I like a little cuticle
did you remember when you're a kid they
tell you you get worm eggs no be raised
by gypsies I've never heard those two
words together my life I've heard the
apple tree if you eat an apple see but
not worm eggs you bite your nails the
devil will take you away all right I got
one the nails put that in the [ __ ]
fire that's something right earmark that
stuff to come back you got that you got
the Costco you got beating the guy up on
the [ __ ] Turnpike this is gonna be
hard you've gotta [ __ ] Ace this thing
from here on out unless you play piano
or something like that we don't know you
got a baby grand nine how are you in a
violin let's start there
does anyone in your family pronounce the
days of the week as Monday Tuesday or
Wednesday I think my mom must you should
we call her now and see [ __ ] hell yeah
we should Greg got off the phone with
her just ask her what the day of the
week is and see what she said okay my
parent my pair
oh my aunts and uncles pronounce
hamburger Hamburg
oh that's trash out here they used to
call the fairy the fairy fairy yeah
she's quarantine she went oh hey MA
hey how do you pronounce the days of the
week say the days of the week okay okay
good
all right thanks what I I think it was a
little bit of a Monday wasn't it I think
she straightened up around - yeah she
knew she knew I was judging her and she
drops her Bronx accent she was I'm so
hard to enunciate I know it did get
clear like she hit Saturday I thought
she was a [ __ ] you know well that's a
very good question Gregory take a look
she did say Sunday twice I don't know if
she's dipping into tell me more do on a
[ __ ] there's your mom's drink
Catholic she wants to make sure she's
emphasizing headliner yeah does your mom
still hit the sauce oh yeah yeah real do
you hit the sauce now he's clean I've
been sober for 31 years wow that's
almost 30 we said this I think last week
or two weeks ago I respond really still
hit the sauce and the other half can't
because they flew too close to the Sun
you know what I mean oh yeah it's like
it's it's down the middle
half-caf camp right what was the the
name of your first email address EF dog
at EarthLink calm and the reason why he
was EF dog was I shared it with my wife
it was Aaron Aaron and Fitzsimmons
I was fitzy so is Erin and fitzy dog at
Earth link back up and we had the same
email address for a long
[ __ ] time Wow keeps you honest I
guess huh yeah it was cheaper yeah yes
back when you had if I can pay for it I
don't even let my girlfriend walk by my
laptop treat her like a dog in the trash
why do you get to other phones in your
side hit her with the shock collar keep
it moving not in the seat all right this
is this one what you know what kind of
candy do you give out on Halloween no
what a [ __ ] question Kevin Ryan this
this separates the trash from the class
it better not be some la [ __ ] either
well we go to Erewhon and we have valet
parking airline we Valley Park at erawan
and they get some soy and they spray it
with rice sun-dried tomato miss you're
giving up a round of cheese the kids in
their hand bring your own crackers kids
bring your own crackers now we've got a
Costco whatever whatever [ __ ] giant
bag you can fund the Fun Pack cool the
fun size that yeah yeah yeah yeah
are you a strict take one or do you let
the kids you know just kind of get it
and get a hand in there and keep it
moving we do a thing we go to my
neighbor's house and he he has a
microphone and a very short mic stand
and when the kids show up we tell them
you get one piece of candy just for
showing up if you want a second one you
have to sing a song or tell a joke and
then the kids house the [ __ ] auntie is
[ __ ] jokes that's fun I do awesome
like four-year-olds telling Joe one kid
goes he says what do you call a fish
with no eyes that's pretty good
there's no fat on that thing baby yeah
you're not getting to snickers out of me
with that [ __ ] I'm hanging out I want to
hear a [ __ ] song give me a knock I'll
give you a Baby Ruth now you get it the
black girls show up and they they will
start telling it and Beyonce don't give
the entire [ __ ] song
I love that Greg if you ever named a
star after anyone somebody gave me that
as a gift once I remember that being the
shittiest kids name names do we know
it's air after you start to talk to that
guy now it was my ex my ex-girlfriend
maybe you know her sue Costello oh yeah
okay
she's a comedian yeah I did something
with her yeah yeah maybe we shouldn't
name names there fair enough no no no I
did some show looking at my laptop I'll
tell you that much Greg still gets hot
where you [ __ ] at right now I'm
getting on a flight have you ever have
you ever done that as a dad have you
ever like had to like really like
threaten somebody that was messing with
the kids or anything like that or
somebody calling the house it was a guy
we went on a camping trip once up here
we go horse First Folio
what did you think the answer he's
punching people out on the [ __ ] 401
you think he's he hasn't threatened any
I want to hear about it losing it on
someone something like second grade art
teacher something like that
yeah we were it was a bunch of parents
and we hadn't we rented a campsite at
Yosemite and one and then my son and
another kid Gus they had a stick and I
guess it was another girl who had a
stick and you know they were like
[ __ ] nine mm-hmm and I guess they
stole the other girls stick and the
father who was a big guy he gotten my
son and Gus's face and he [ __ ]
screamed at them and he threatened them
it's on my publicist he was hysterically
crying
you might even been younger than nine
and he came to Isis and I just said
where is he and I went up to his tent
and I walked up to him and I did the
classic remember the chest bump oh yeah
and the only reason I was able to his
chest because he was he was down a hill
and I was above them so I walked into
him and I said I said you got one hour
to pack your [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out
of my hamster what and he just started
packing he packed up all his [ __ ] and
then what the [ __ ]
my wife my wife is screaming at me and
so I went back and I told him he could
stay to talk about it Ollie make a flex
on some I thought you wrote of pack your
[ __ ] there's no I'll let ya this is me
allowing you and your family to enjoy
yourselves remember that the Fitz dog
calls the shots around here I'd be the
only thing about being Irish we went out
to ice cream that night
when you're Irish you heat up but then
you cool that Oh coldest fistfights with
my best friends later that night of
course
wait you would have to ice cream with
the guy yeah a bunch of us went out holy
[ __ ]
huh yeah a little rocky road to smooth
things over with a side of bipolar
please dude I had no I was expecting so
I walk up to my chest bump them I said
you better apologize right now telling a
guy to pack up his [ __ ] [ __ ] he
probably gets one two weeks vacation a
year okay this guy's on vacation and
you're go tell your kids are going
[ __ ] home and cut my lawn on the
[ __ ] way blow and go my lawn let's do
it God that is [ __ ] crazy is
something else right now
Curtis [ __ ] nuts pack your [ __ ]
you're going home
you and your daughter who's crying now
back her up yeah you just ruined her
vacation and scholar and for quite some
time she was made no I said you're gonna
apologize to my son and Gus and then
you're gonna pack your [ __ ] that girl
definitely has some father ish you loo
dude if somebody you just made a
stripper that's basically what you did
you made a stripper and she's gonna have
a stick on stage nobody know what she'll
be breaking in the money with this dick
dude if someone came up to my dad while
we were on vacation and told him to pack
his [ __ ] and go and he started if he
even put a sock in a bag I would have
been like dude I'm driving the [ __ ] home
give me these you stink I'm out of here
but that's the difference it's the guys
that don't that your dad would never do
that to a kid of course right and like
that's the thing the tough guys they
don't [ __ ] act like yeah they don't
say that kind of [ __ ] right but they
will [ __ ]
engine that's it I remember my dad told
the neighbor one time he the kid was
like 15 hey me and my brother were like
I don't know like six and eight or
something and he like punched my brother
or pushed me or something my dad walked
he was like kid was like a young
teenager my dad hit him with the line
I'm gonna clean your clock and I was
like dad is some [ __ ] old-school
Philly [ __ ] right there you just told a
15 year old your do you got any of those
that you break out do you have any do
you have any sayings like that that you
hit the kids with what do I say to Mike
well my son is 19 now and that's okay
sit he's a varsity athlete he's [ __ ]
ripped and he's just taller than me we
did a lot of slap fighting a lot of rest
yeah and then the other night I choked
him out he finally tapped but I choked
him out we still wrestle we still go at
it and I had him he was red he had tears
rolling down his face at the table and
he finally I had him fully around back
of the head he had no he had no way out
jeez what's the [ __ ] don't you write for
a Disney show right now so I put Ellen
in the [ __ ] sleeper old Irish
Catholic trashy thing too is like we
need the teenage when the boy gets into
his teenager
oh man good toe off your peacock around
the house yeah and my dad would always
hit me with I got one more good one left
in than you want it because end of the
day he knows I will fight to my death I
can't lose the office can you can I
would move I look and move become a
caddy again and like son son be home at
11:00 I bet you go [ __ ] yourself
okay cool anybody flexing on either one
like the flinch move on your [ __ ] yeah
you turned in the Biff at the end of
back to the future okay no problem I'll
put the second coat on the car right now
[ __ ] wild how do you feel about the
comedy of mr. bean when I was when I my
kids were kids
mm-hmm they enjoyed it and I liked them
like you like anything your kids like
yeah you got the kids card I think he
does what he does extremely well
yeah not my type of comedy but he's very
talented
okay all right I'm left Foley at some
point took a legal pad and wrote down
the words mr. bean on it
and you know what ironing around the way
he's goin like you're dane cook mr. bean
I don't know I thought I was gonna get a
laugh I don't know mr. bean was the [ __ ]
growing I took a shot what do you want
these are hook we're just riffing here
Greg let's all smoke and mirrors over
here I think you're gonna get mad at me
for a second he was on the camping trip
with me he was Gus his dad it was name
was Gus [ __ ]
he's British they [ __ ] subjugated our
Island for 700 years starved us to death
of the 19th century now we're cooking
have you ever been to a BYOB strip club
no oh nice last class when was the last
time you were at a strip club it alone T
criminate yourself my authority no
you're a mariano if you're still sharing
the emails there was a place in LA
that's kind of fun it's called Jumbo's
clown room I've heard about that yeah
yeah and it's like it's just like a down
and dirty dive bar that has strippers
and they're not necessarily good-looking
or young but they all have like a hook
you know like you know like some of them
have like bare feet and they'll stick
their feet on your face some of them
dress up as a cowgirl don't like the mob
strippers yeah prop servers and one girl
used to light her vagina on fire so she
was kind of famous she was kind of
famous for it and so I came in one week
and I go hey where's the girl that uh
used to light her vagina on fire and and
they go oh we had to let her go she had
some she had some mental stuff she's
like they're [ __ ] on fire did she
really
hello
really Jesus brothers broads [ __ ]
torch in her clam every night for a
couple of [ __ ] she told me she was
premed what's going on here okay I keep
going to get your tonsils out hey aren't
you the [ __ ] the clam burner as a
Catholic gentlemen
I would like to discuss Christmas yeah
with you if I could um decorate the
house of Christmas yeah you do colored
lights you do white lights on the
outside color Oh y-you got the cash
let's go kid
yeah I grew up with it with that [ __ ]
baby ones yeah yeah and you know he
wants one of those crack that would kill
you the voltage now the new ones one
goes out the whole [ __ ] strip goes
out with the old ones you just get
another Bowl you know you keep the dream
alive yeah they were regular [ __ ]
balls you've got those in like in your
chandelier in the foyer you need it
right right and then but the real the
real trash was a lot of tinsel on top do
you still do that Greg that that's the
mayonnaise of Christmas that's the
Miracle Whip of Chris yeah I assume
you're a Hellmann's man I would like to
think no I'm a Costco Costco guy well
that's all right so yeah that's all
right that's not bad
okay all right do you do tinsel now
still yeah yeah right here what you're
not doing popcorn on the tree are you
okay do you have one or two trees one
tree all right no you could have one for
the butler I don't know no Italians do a
lot of Italians do to trees
I wasn't once typically real some real
gaudy guinea [ __ ] - it's like red or
[ __ ] blue sometimes we're talking -
virzi puts it on the ceiling they do an
upside down tree it's real Viking
real [ __ ] [ __ ] they doing outside
no it's just inverted it just goes the
other way I don't know yeah
Bensonhurst oh that's the greatest once
they shake you down for a little bit of
cash out there you're gonna go yeah
because they're electric bill is about
you guys go you guys go real tree to go
artificial tree now real tree okay yeah
feel like Craig's mad at me he's just
afraid of older Irishman it's just as
upbringing now we used to we get the
tree every year there's a lot and you
know the mob owns all the Lots because
it's just a cash business short short
they can bury that money yeah so there's
a lot that the mob wounds of the street
and this one guy every year gets us our
tree and he's he's this old black guy
and he's always drunk but he said oh
he's a drunk yeah yeah and he sings the
whole time
he sings Christmas carols huh that's and
then you give him a big [ __ ] tip love
it and then and I always thought wow
this guy this guy makes a really good
living and then my family we we serve
food at a homeless shelter and then he
should he shows up one week and I was
like where do you let I go I thought you
were pretty well-off he's like no I've
been homeless for like 12 years I'm like
Oh Craigs like I thought you were
well-off I gave you 40 bucks once a year
oh yeah I guess this job only lasts
about three weeks yeah yeah oh that's
[ __ ] great let's do we're coming up
on an hour here let's get some of the
are you garbage basics these are ones
that we go over with everybody the
listeners have a very are very
opinionated about these answers yes so
the house you live in now I'm assuming
is a single-family home Greg no we have
a rental unit in the back that we rent
out
this guy's got [ __ ] passive income
streams on the property oh that's right
hey all right
are currently a tenant in there right
now that's right this pilot seasons
coming up great you don't want that this
is the almond butter that's a big catch
um do you have a garage currently no we
converted it into a we have a two-car
garage uh-huh we converted it into a
giant bonus room we've got some hardwood
floors put in floor is nice that's very
nice couple doors little bathroom okay I
got two questions first question do you
have to step down into that new room now
oh very nice very nice also do you have
a refrigerator in that room it's do you
have a second fridge in the house or are
you just a one fridge family it's a mini
fridge Oh fair enough go there you go
not too what's in that mini fridge Greg
final final question with the fridge
it's just beer nice what did ya for
guests and my son nice that would
qualify as what we like to refer to it
are you garbage the garage fridge if you
don't have a nice garage fridge with
[ __ ] ice pops for the kids and
[ __ ] beers for dad and your uncle
Hank right you're trash right a second
fridge is the American dream baby it is
do you currently with dinner to the
children or to you and your wife serve
milk while you're eating well you have
milk with dinner I like that you say
milk yes I say it and everybody gives me
[ __ ] a [ __ ] that's all garbage I must
have picked it up in that one year I
lived in Cherry Hill New Jersey
no tell you herpes you never get rid of
it you get [ __ ] about how you say milk
the listeners [ __ ] they spell it
Emmy LK now my daughter yeah my daughter
drinks milk with dinner
did you drink milk with dinner growing
up oh [ __ ] yeah
we used to drink it
there we go do you remember those shrimp
cocktail glasses that used to get it was
a little glad huh the top on it filled
with shrimp cocktail yeah and and my
parents kept those oh hi all's about
[ __ ] six ounces and I don't drink milk
out of it dinner every wow that's pretty
[ __ ] fancy that's like Gatsby [ __ ] I
like that
holy [ __ ] if you're saving the glass
from this room drink ya know hate t here
strap trash that's how trashy he is
you're drinking milk out of what I would
refer to as a champagne glass that's
pretty [ __ ] good to me
I was drinking it out of a coffee mug at
dinner at nine years old that said
number one bad on it I think I just got
one last one how do you feel about
imitation crabmeat yes no problem with
that yeah I'm actually shocked I mean
it's like you know you have to give me
one of the other and I had to guess I
don't know the difference all about fake
crab me yeah i go to i go to Ralph's
which is the shitty grocery store some
huh yeah and they have pre-made
whatever the roles are that have is it
is it the California California yeah
yeah with the fake crab in it all over
that
oh that's trash all right I would have
to say where were we at it we are we
right there what do you think he think
he's garbage think he's not God there is
not a doubt in my mind he is garbage
threw in yeah I mean he was less garbage
it sounds when he was you know a six
year old ordered of the coke off Kevin
meanie at the country club then he
starts working at the country club
that's a hard left right there you can't
go from a [ __ ] member to caddy I just
want to ask when you only get two
dollars a day to eat no shrimp cocktail
there I can tell you that yeah one final
question at the high your house now
where do you keep the ketchup after
you've opened did he keep it in the
refrigerator or do you leave it in the
cabinet people leave in the cabinet no
yeah great
sir Craig after opening right at the
bottom and how about your maple syrup
you leave that in the in the in the
fridge yes
smart man yeah what one more while we're
on it this is and they're gonna lock on
this guy he's like probably uh a
wallpaper can't get a read on him do you
butter do you keep butter on the counter
or do you keep it in the refrigerator on
the counter oh this guy's [ __ ]
garbage yes
holy [ __ ] old-school Irish [ __ ] that's
garbage
that's it that's a wrap that's a wrap on
Finn wrap Greg Fitzsimmons is garbage
I'll tell you that right now
the best kind of garbage Greg is there
anything you want the folks out there to
know anything you got coming up do you
want to do you want to let us sit on no
dates obviously but I got three podcasts
I get Fitz dog radio which is me
interviewing other comedians and writers
directors and then I have a new one
that I'm really excited about called
Sunday papers that I do with my buddy
Mike Gibbons he's a big showrunner he
created a bunch of TV shows like David
Spade's first show on Comedy Central and
okay tosh point-o so we read the paper
every Sunday we've read each section of
the paper and we do jokes about it and
it's it's very funny and then I was nice
another one called childish I do with
Alison Rosen where we talk about raising
kids she's got babies I got teenagers
and we talk about raising kids on
awesome well buddy thank you so much for
coming on the show we really really
appreciate it was real I wish we could
do it in person next time I'm in New
York we'll do it yeah sure ma'am could
be anything looks out there - no yeah
Cameron comedy on all social media and
you know rate review subscribe on iTunes
and also on YouTube thanks guys very
nice @h Foley ah nice on Twitter and
Foley Graham's on Instagram just to
reiterate what Kevin said we thank you
guys so much for listening we'll be back
next week and shout out to everybody in
the live chat shout out to our producer
Dylan the kid our executive producer
Bobby the hutch and of course the entire
gash digital family we will see you guys
next week thank you so you